ah so uh I recently came upon the work
of a Jewish mystic from the 1920s named
Martin Buber who wrote his book called I
and thou and the book was kind of
amazing in it he made the case that
there's actually two types of human
relationships and I each relationships
in an I vow relationship and here's how
it works and I it relationship is
essentially a transactional relationship
is the kind of relationship that you
have with another person that collapses
a being into somebody that serves a
function for you with transactional and
instrumentalist for example the
relationship you have with your waiter
he's the waiter and you order your food
or the relationship you have with an
uber driver or the relationship you have
with a bank teller essentially again a
person takes on a utilitarian function
it's a transactional and instrumentalist
exchange and Martin Buber actually says
that these kinds of transactions i-it
transactions are actually necessary in
order to take on roles and create a
functional society where each person
takes on a particular task that's fine
the problem is when these transactional
instrumentalist relationships are all
that we have this is when we start to
feel alienated and disconnected because
we don't have the other kind of
relationship which are much more
nourishing that he calls I vow
relationships so I vow relationships are
actually encounters he calls them
encounters and this is when you meet
another being in their totality free of
the instrumentalist agenda free of using
them as a means to an end
so rather than collapsing a human being
into the function that they serve there
is no instrumentalist transaction but
rather an encounter with the entirety of
another person with the cosmos that is
another person and when you are able to
encounter another without filter
unvarnished this kind of transaction
becomes what he calls the
intersubjective these encounters these
inter subjective encounters where two
minds meet creates this space that
uber calls the between and the between
this inner subjective cosmology opened
up between two people during an I thou
encounter is where God lives this is the
holy space rendered real by a meeting of
two souls and so again he makes sure to
be clear he's not saying that we should
never have I it encounters we need
transactional and instrumentalist
relationships to organize societies but
we need to temper these to mitigate
these with also full-on encounters with
the inter subjective where you actually
meet another soul so perhaps the crisis
of our age is that our capitalist system
has turned everybody into a commodity
and we've made no space we've made no
containers to meet people in these inter
subjective i thou encounters so maybe
that's what we need to architect that's
what we need to create to nourish the
faint disquiet the existential dread
that afflicts so many of our souls and
so many of our psyches